bloomberg will ins weiße haus der
milliardär und frühere bürgermeister von
new york könnte das demokratische
bewerberfeld gegen donald trump
durcheinanderwirbeln test für die
demokratiebewegung in hongkong hofft die
opposition bei bezirks wahlen auf viele
stimmen und höchste alarmstufe nach
dauerregen in frankreich sterben zwei
menschen in italien stürzt eine
autobahnbrücke ein
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber einen guten
sonntagabend hinein hier ist ihr
überblick über die nachrichtenlage heute
um 7 mit sport und mit polizei
hallo genannt das rennen ums weiße haus
in den usa bekommt einen neuen
mitbewerber der für wirbel sorgt michael
bloomberg milliardär und frühere
bürgermeister von new york city will
präsidentschaftskandidat der demokraten
werden
bloomberg ist 77 jahre alt er sagt heute
ich steige in den wahlkampf ein um
donald trump zu schlagen und amerika
wieder aufzubauen
für die präsidentschaftskandidatur der
demokratischen partei gibt es damit 18
bewerbern
mehr dazu von britta jäger für uns in
washington britta guten abend michael
bloomberg wird auf mehr als 50
milliarden dollar vermögen geschätzt wie
sehr wird denn das allein diesen
wahlkampf durcheinanderwirbeln also
michael bloomberg hatte im märz
eigentlich beschlossen dass er nicht
sich bewerben wird für die demokratische
präsidentschaftskandidatur weil damals
joe biden ins rennen gegangen ist und
die beiden männer verfolgen eine
ähnliche liberale agenda und er wollte
er joe biden wohl nicht in die quere
kommen aber jetzt wo joe biden
schwächelt da sieht michael bloomberg
noch einmal eine große chance für sich
und die hat er auch denn wie sie gerade
gesagt haben er ist milliardenschwer und
geld spielt im amerikanischen wahlkampf
ja immer eine wichtige wenn nicht
manchmal sogar die entscheidende rolle
michael bloomberg hat bereits
angekündigt dass er einen beträchtlichen
teil seines vermögens in seine kampagne
buttern will und das dürfte natürlich
den anderen demokratischen
präsidentschaftskandidaten überhaupt
nicht gefallen
allen voran den linken kandidaten nicht
gefallen und ich vermute auch sehr stark
dass donald trump diesen doch sehr
speziellen kandidaten jetzt noch einmal
mehr als bedrohung empfinden wird denn
er wird sich wahrscheinlich auf ihn ein
schießen in den nächsten wochen in den
nächsten monaten in kleinen vorgeschmack
haben wir schon erlebt in den letzten
tagen oder vor einigen tagen als der
berichte kamen dass michael bloomberg
sich jetzt doch ins rennen rein begibt
da hat trump gesagt dem kleinen michael
fehle die nö
die magie um ihn zu schlagen wir werden
das sehen
unter vielen dank nach washington und
die menschen in hongkong sind heute in
rekordzahl zur wahl gegangen mehr als
jemals zuvor die bezirks wahlen sind die
einzigen dort die als tatsächlich
demokratisch gelten
das ergebnis wird einiges aussagen
angesichts der monatelangen proteste der
demokratiebewegung auch über die frage
wie viele wähler die demonstrationen
unterstützen bislang beherrscht das treu
zur führung in peking stehende
regierungslager rund drei viertel der
bezirksrats posten in hongkong dollar
berichtet bereits morgens um acht stehen
sie schlange um zu wählen
eigentlich geht es nur um eine
kommunalwahl die an der macht
architektur in hongkong nichts ändern
wird
aber die letzten monate mit
massendemonstrationen und gewalt haben
hongkongs bürger aufgewühlt vor allem
die unterstützer der pro demokratie
kandidaten wollen eine botschaft senden
wir müssen wählen gehen damit zeigen wir
unsere regierung als auch peking dass
wir für freiheit und demokratie sind die
anhänger der pro peking kandidaten
hoffen auf einen sieg als zeichen dass
hongkong ein ende der proteste will die
hongkonger regierung ist viel zu nett zu
den demonstranten ich bin mir sicher sie
besetzen die weisheit das problem bald
zu lösen
die wahl verlief ruhig keine
gewalttätigen ausschreitungen mit der
polizei
die hielt sich im hintergrund die
hongkonger bürger sind zufrieden dass
die wahlen friedlich stattgefunden haben
das ist ein kleiner sieg für die
demokratie und die hohe wahlbeteiligung
könnte darauf hinweisen dass vor allem
peking kritische kandidaten gewonnen
haben und das wäre dann mehr rückhalt
für die demonstranten
die auszählung der stimmen wird noch die
ganze nacht andauern
erste ergebnisse morgen nach deutschland
dort droht einem projekt der
bundesregierung das aus bayern und baden
württemberg erklären heute sie wollten
beim geplanten nationalen bildungsgrad
nicht mitmachen
man brauche keine vorgaben aus berlin
der rat sollte unter anderem für gleiche
qualitätsstandards an den schulen sorgen
bundesbildungsministerin annette dauert
die absage
dauerregen sturm überschwemmungen in
frankreich und italien waren am
wochenende tausende rettungskräfte
unterwegs ein erdrutsch riss die trasse
der autobahn a6 bei savona in ligurien
mit es klafft ein 30 meter großes loch
verletzt wurde glücklicherweise niemand
in frankreich werden bisher zwei tote
gemeldet es hat vor allem den süden
erwischt in der gesamten gegend zwischen
marseille und nizza mussten tausende
evakuiert werden christel hs fasst
zusammen eine seenlandschaft so weit das
auge reicht
und mittendrin ortschaften meter hoch
steht das wasser in den straßen
die weißen flecken in dieser braunen
brühe sind autodächer allen warnungen
zum trotz wagen sich autofahrer in die
fluten mit dem erwartbaren ergebnis
die ganze nacht über waren die
rettungskräfte damit beschäftigt
menschen aus notsituationen zu retten
auch mit dem hubschrauber das wasser
stand mir bis zur brust sie kamen mit
dem helikopter haben ein gitter
weggerissen damit ich ausgaben ich
dachte das sei in vielen häusern sieht
es jetzt besucher aus unser kühlschrank
ist umgekippt das zeigt wie stark die
kraft des wassers war genauso betroffen
von den unwettern norditalien einer
autobahnbrücke wurde westlich von genua
von einem erdrutsch weggerissen die
fahrbahn endet jetzt in einem gähnenden
abgrund
es grenzt an ein wunder dass niemand in
die tiefe gerissen wurde
auch in diesem ort hat eine
schlammlawine verwüstungen angerichtet
es wird wohl wochen dauern bis die
schäden beseitigt sind pervers und
unentschuldbar so nennt papst franziskus
allein schon den besitz von atomwaffen
in japan forderte er jetzt das aus für
alle nuklearwaffen und zwar weltweit und
sofort in nagasaki traf franziskus
menschen die den einsatz einer atombombe
überlebt haben
gedenken genau dort wo 1945 das zentrum
der explosion war als die usa eine
atombombe auf nagasaki waffen und auf
hiroshima auch dort erinnerte franziskus
an die vielen toten hunderttausende
menschen starben sofort oder an den
folgen stellen
jetzt machen wir die sendungen schnitt
kommt zum sport am sonntag mit rooney
genau und im wintersport geht es wieder
zur sache weltcup auftakt an diesem
wochenende in eis und schnee zum
abschluss des ersten rodel weltcup in
innsbruck igls erreichte die
mixed-staffel den dritten platz für die
deutschen skispringer endete der weltcup
in polen noch ohne podestplatz
das frustrierende ende eine zunächst
aussichtsreichen tages karl geiger
führender nach dem ersten durchgang feld
schlussendlich der polnischen
windlotterie zum opfer der norweger
daniel andere tanne geht als zweitbester
ins finale
bei guten bedingungen 129 meter rang
eins dann folgt geiger der sprung vom
winde verweht nur 118 meter der
26-jährige verpasst das podest deutlich
als siebter während an bejubelt kein
gelungener einstand für neue
bundestrainer stefan horngacher
durchwachsener auftakt für die deutschen
rodler in die weltcup-saison
vorjahressieger johannes ludwig bringt
sich in innsbruck schon im ersten lauf
um alle chancen auf eine vordere
platzierung weltmeister felix loch liegt
da zwar noch viel versprechende auf rang
drei im zweiten lauf fällt er dann aber
auf platz sechs zurück den sieg vor
heimpublikum holt sich der österreicher
jonas müller auf platz drei beim sieg
von italien in der anschließenden team
staffel war nur ein kleines bösen
drachen und das erste sonntagsspiel der
fußball bundesliga gewinnt augsburg
deutlich mit 4 0 gegen hertha bsc
für die berliner die vierte niederlage
nacheinander
auf der mitgliederversammlung von
borussia dortmund ernteten die bvb
profis heute schallende pfiffe für
zuletzt enttäuschende leistungen
[Musik]
und dann äußert sich geschäftsführer
watzke wenig verheißungsvoll zur zukunft
von trainer lucien favre
lucia du hast auch weiter unser
vertrauen
aber es ist auch eins plan und du bist
schon so lange im fußball dabei wie
viele von uns auch am ende ist fußball
auch immer über ergebnisse definiert von
zwei spielen auf bewährung ist die rede
in barcelona und bei hertha bsc und die
dankeschön an die tiere schauen wir noch
aufs wetter morgen das hat auch kein
jubel verdient leider nur noch ein
bisschen sonne meist bleibt es bedeckt
oder neblig-trüb temperaturen maximal
fünf bis zehn grad und in den nächsten
tagen weiterhin mild einigermaßen
zumindest aber zunehmend nasa mehr zu
diesem tag vom kollegen claus kleber
heute journal um 21.45 wir sehen uns
gerne gleich morgen montag wieder um 19
uhr vom gesamten team danke fürs
zuschauen ihnen allen einen angenehmen
sonntagabend zum beispiel mit berlin
direkt und chocolat banerjee haluschak
und dollar